as a feeling in Trump World that his big
mistake and I think Trump even sort of
slightly acknowledged it that his big
mistake was he tried to work with
Washington he didn't fully go to war
with Washington and destroy all the
institutions of American government as
he should have done so I think he'd be
emboldened to do that again he would
find that it's harder to do in practice
than in rhetoric but I think the way
he's talking about the Deep State now I
mean it's very very incendiary he said
recently you know I will be your
retribution this is almost a Biblical
talk and I think that is that's going to
be if he wins with that kind of angry
message uh then I think you're going to
see a much Bolder Trump in 2024 if he
wins